so we do uh some of things we actually
video everything that's going on and
then you could look at the video and
then reflect on it and one of the things
I found is that um some people when they
look at
their uh
mistakes react differently than other
people when they look at their mistakes
do you find
that again it's we try to make it very
professional and you know if now
sometimes there's a disagreement about
the mistake
uh you know well I did this well
somebody told me to do that that was you
know somebody instructed me to do that
they made a call on the field or this is
the way the coach explained it and then
we have to get to the bottom of that
like all right well you were told the
wrong thing or no you thought they told
you to do that that isn't what they were
telling you to do you know whatever the
communication breakdown is so um so
people will easily own their mistakes
there's not some people who will not as
well own their mistakes
again the it'll vary or not every once
in a while you'll get some situations
where it's not clearcut exactly what
went wrong or maybe it's a combination
of things maybe maybe a player didn't
run a good route and maybe it wasn't a
good throw and maybe there was a
protection breakdown that caused the
quarterback to not have you know and so
maybe it's a combination of things I
find it more difficult I find a lot of
people um not a lot some I think it's
very big differentiator between people
who will own their mistakes
and easily learn of and I suspect it's
probably because of of their used to
probably when they were growing up yeah
in the in playing their game all the way
through to when the time that they got
there that's just the way it is in in
our case um people have to some people
are more used to being handle with kid
gloves and you know and it's not as easy
to be straightforward and saying okay
and then say I got it I own that
mistake